dr david agus joins us now from los
angeles to separate fact from fiction
when it comes to treatment of the virus
david good morning
good morning there's so much
misinformation about there about out
there about the ways to treat this virus
and
its symptoms can you help us separate
fact from fiction here uh
starting with what we we've been hearing
about ibuprofen
there was some data out of france where
a statement was made that ibuprofen can
dramatically
increase symptoms of the virus and it's
just not true it is okay to take tylenol
is it okay to take ibuprofen there is no
association with severity and symptoms
or outcome
to the virus and then we're seeing it
with herbs and supplements and vitamins
i am getting barraged with hundreds of
emails a day
and there is no data that any of them
work
and what i don't want people to do is
take one of them and go into a more high
risk behavior because they say hey
i'm protected because i'm taking x or
i'm taking y
i want people to realize that social
distancing while it's not sexy and it
doesn't come as a pill in a bottle
it is the only thing that really works
against this horrible virus
david i heard something i've been doing
it for the past week i got
something online a lot of people got
this if you hold your breath for 10
seconds
and you don't experience any discomfort
that's a sign that maybe you're doing
okay
does that and it allegedly came from
doctors at stanford
have you heard anything like that yeah
i've got i got so many copies of that
email it is totally
unfortunately made up and it is not true
um
you can stop holding your breath and you
can breathe
i was only doing then i was i was so
proud of myself because i was going for
20 seconds yeah then you'll pass out
yeah yeah gail found on floor after
holding breath
yeah i know so what do you what do you
make of the stories we're hearing about
older people who are not really
following the social distancing rules
we have to stress how important this is
when we look at the south korea data
south korea is the most analogous system
to us in terms of medical care and they
have an excellent infrastructure
the death rate in people over 80 years
old was over eight percent
70 to 80 the death rate was five and a
half percent
um 60 to 70 the death rate was three and
a half percent under 60 the death rate
was about 0.1 percent
so the key is if you are older six over
60. no matter how healthy you think you
are
no matter how much you can run and jog
and do whatever
you were still at dramatically high risk
for complication and even death from
this virus
so you have to listen to these
guidelines please please please
the reason our country is going through
these aggressive measures
is to protect the people over 60. yeah
they have to play along and i really
hope they do
and the people who are not over 60
needed to remember that what they do can
have an effect on those people in that
more vulnerable category
dr david agus thank you very much